gerade schon gehört es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche meinung dazu ob das die
richtige entscheidung war oder nicht wie
schätzen sie das ein hat der berliner
senat recht damit und vor allem ist es
auch etwas was man überhaupt darf dass
der staat jetzt so eine demo verbietet
wenn er andere weiterhin erlaubt der
staat kann durchaus demonstrationen
verbieten wenn er an tragfähigen grund
hat in diesem fall ist die aussage dass
die gesundheit und das leben gefährdet
wird weil man sich weigert mundschutz
und ähnliche vorschriften die bestehen
zum schutz gegen die pandemie weil man
die nicht einhalten will
das ist grundsätzlich möglich aber es
besteht natürlich immer die gefahr bei
einem so schweren eingriff wie ein
verbot
das sogenannte - maßnahmen geben muss
das heißt es muss genau geprüft werden
ob nicht auflagen bedingungen und
detaillierte vorgaben die in kooperation
zwischen der polizei und den
veranstalter gewonnen werden müssen ob
die nicht ausreichend das ist im moment
die entscheidende frage die
organisatoren der demonstration haben
jetzt rechtsmittel eingelegt wie groß
sind ihre chancen ihrer meinung nach und
vor allem wie schnell das gehen kann es
sein dass das samstag gegeben und dann
doch noch gibt
natürlich das ist ja ganz normal es gibt
es oft solche verfahren die werden
innerhalb von zwei tagen wie nichts vom
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
das ist überhaupt kein problem das fängt
an beim verwaltungsgericht in berlin
angeht zum oberverwaltungsgericht und
sie können davon ausgehen dass man in
karlsruhe auch schon vorbereitungen
getroffen hat um diese fragen dann
gegebenenfalls schnell zu entscheiden
und wie hoch schätzen sie denn die
chancen ein dass die demonstranten recht
bekommen wenn es den meisten gelingt
nachzuweisen dass sie ein konzept haben
ein überzeugendes konzept haben um die
sicherheit zu gewährleisten dass keine
ansteckungsgefahren dadurch entstehen
dann haben sie eine chance aber nach dem
wie sie sich in der vergangenen und in
der vergangenen demonstration verhalten
haben
spricht das nicht dafür dass es gelingen
wird und wenn sie sich äußerungen aus
dem kreis der beteiligten anhören dann
sind die auch schon doch eher geeignet
nicht wenn davon die rede ist über eine
million über eine million wird man nicht
auf der straße sitzen junis unterbringen
können unter kroner bedingungen
jetzt wird trotzdem aufgerufen zu ja
dass die leute trotzdem deutschlandweit
herkommen sollen es wird mobilisiert
egal ob sie jetzt recht bekommen oder
nicht selbst wenn die demo verboten
bleibt was bedeutet dass juristisch für
all diejenigen die sich am wochenende
dann also trotzdem treffen auf der
straße 17 juni hier in berlin
wenn das gericht die verbotsverfügung
bestätigt dann wird die versammlung
aufgelöst werden und wie das geht das
kennt man ja auch aus dem fernsehen
nicht
wasserwerfer notfalls also es wird nicht
so sein wie beim letzten mal anfang
august ist viel zu wenig polizeibeamte
machtlos den demonstranten
gegenüberstehen die sagen wir gehen ja
nicht weg wir bleiben hier und das wird
mit sicherheit nicht passieren
erlauben sie noch eine bemerkung weil
das in ihrem vor im trailer eine rolle
spielte die bemerkung natürlich des
innensenators dass sich nicht auf der
nase herumtanzen lassen will
von das ist natürlich völlig daneben das
war eine fehlentscheidung die unter
umständen auch noch auf die füße fallen
wird weil ich unter umständen die
gerichte sagen na ja die waren belohnung
ist ja gar nicht die gefahrenabwehr
sondern die gewarnten ihr passt die
ganze richtung nicht dazu ist als
innensenator nicht befugt das feld auf
meine nächste frage gewesen wie
juristisch sauber die arbeit von senator
geisel war weil natürlich zum einen wird
über das verbot diskutiert es wird aber
auf jeder über diskutiert wie er es eben
dann bei diesem statement verkauft hat
muss man fast sagen ihre einschätzung
also das war keine gute arbeit so ein
klassisches selbst